[Aplausos]
[Música]
una de las preguntas que nos soléis
hacer en visualpolitik es cómo
encontráis tema para un vídeo Pues bien
el vídeo de hoy es uno de esos temas que
ha estado delante de todos durante todo
este año y casi nadie se ha dado cuenta
de lo sorprendente que es atentos a esta
noticia el comodín se une al esfuerzo
militar ruso las fuerzas leales al señor
de la guerra del cáucaso han sido una
parte integral del plan militar del
crimen desde el comienzo la noticia en
este caso es que esto sea noticia pensad
así tenía es una región de Rusia es
obvio que si Rusia invade un país habrá
tropas chechenas al igual que tropas de
cualquier otra región rusa
[Música]
sin embargo lo cierto Es que ranzam
kadir off tiene su propio ejército un
ejército con un gran nivel de
Independencia y según las estimaciones
porque no se sabe con certeza unos
12.000 soldados conocidos por ser
especialmente crueles O sea que estamos
diciendo que hay una región que tiene su
propio ejército cuya lealtad no es hacia
el presidente del país Además este
ejército está financiado en parte con
fondos del propio kremlin y ya sé lo que
pensará alguno donde está el problema
Siempre han existido ejércitos privados
o incluso milicias regionales Y sí
tenéis razón el problema es que
chechenia no es una región cualquiera en
las últimas tres décadas han tenido dos
guerras de Independencia con Rusia si
hay una región convulsa en toda la
federación rusa esa es precisamente
chechenia
[Música]
de hecho podríamos decir que tiene un
encaje dentro del Estado ruso bastante
especial por no decir otra cosa peor
habéis oído bien muchos dan por sentado
que Rusia es un país indivisible y que
todos sus ciudadanos desde San
Petersburgo hasta la divostok se sienten
orgullosos hijos de la madre Rusia pero
lo cierto Es que hay partes de la
federación rusa que se sostienen con
alfileres y chenia es una de ellas Así
que la pregunta es hasta qué punto
podemos decir que cadirov tiene un
ejército paralelo al ruso Hasta qué
punto la lealtad hacia el resto de Rusia
es inquebrantable hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
la sicilia del cáucaso
puede que sorprenda pero la historia de
checkenia tiene muy poco que ver con la
historia de Rusia de hecho mientras la
religión mayoritaria de Rusia es el
cristianismo ortodoxo los chechenos son
musulmanes pero no solo eso tienen
incluso su propio idioma y hasta 1920 se
escribía con caracteres Árabes en
realidad esto no es algo único de esta
región la federación rusa tiene varias
de lo que llaman repúblicas
independientes es decir regiones con un
estatus especial porque tienen su propia
cultura e idioma o incluso historia en
el caso que nos ocupa hoy los chechenos
son uno de los pueblos más antiguos del
cáucaso a lo largo de su historia han
sido conquistados por la Rusia y Arista
Sí pero también por otros imperios como
el mongol habiendo servido a tantos
imperios distintos los chechanos
terminaron desarrollando sus propias
instituciones ajenas al Invasor de turno
hablamos de redes de clanes familiares
muy parecidas a lo que durante siglos
fue la mafia siciliana dicho de otra
forma por mucho que los zares invadieran
chechenia durante buena parte del siglo
XIX ellos obedecían antes al patriarca
de su clan que a cualquier funcionario
venido de Moscú de hecho en 1917 varios
de estos clanes intenta crear un estado
soberano independiente la República
montañosa del caucas Norte incluso
llegaron a estar reconocidos por varios
actores internacionales sin embargo en
1922 la unión soviética conquistó el
país
y qué creéis que ocurrió en ese momento
pues que por mucho que el kremlin se
esforzara en rusificar ese lugar los
chechenos mantuvieron las lealtades al
patriarca de turno poco importaron las
deportaciones masivas de la época de
stalin ellos siguieron teniendo una
República soviética pero solo de nombre
para que veáis lo mal que se llevaban
con los rusos los chechenos llegaron a
colaborar con los nazis durante la
Segunda Guerra Mundial en contra de la
URSS y así es como llegamos hasta 1991
que como ya sabéis es el año en el que
la unión soviética se disolvió en este
momento muchas repúblicas soviéticas se
independizaron Ese es el caso de Ucrania
Armenia azerbaiyán Y por supuesto los
chechenos también intentaron tener su
propia República la República chechana
de ifteria y aquí es donde viene la gran
diferencia porque Ucrania se independizó
sin grandes problemas más y lo mismo
ocurrió con muchas otras repúblicas en
muchos casos estos nuevos gobiernos
estaban regidos por los mismos políticos
de la era soviética algunos cambios
cosméticos pero en esencia las mismas
personas sin embargo el caso de
chechania fue muy distinto en este caso
Rusia no aceptó su independencia Y
diréis por qué pues podemos encontrar
muchísimas razones entre otras el zumo
de dinosaurio Y es que sí la región
tiene yacimientos de petróleo pero
también hay un montón de razones
políticas en las que no vamos a entrar
porque sino Este vídeo duraría 3 horas
Lo importante es que en 1994 Rusia
invadió a chechania para neutralizar a
los separatistas y aquí es cuando
llegamos a la Primera Guerra chechena en
un primer momento parecía que iba a ser
un paseo militar para el ejército ruso
pensando así una región pobre y pequeña
frente a una potencia militar hacia 1994
apenas Tenían un millón 300.000
habitantes y enfrente Aunque debilitada
Rusia seguía siendo una potencia militar
sin embargo la Primera Guerra de escena
fue un enorme fracaso para Moscú tanto
es así que en 1999 firmaron un alto el
fuego y tuvieron que retirarse y
pensaréis que esto supuso un conflicto
congelado verdad pues no de hecho Ahí es
donde comenzó la auténtica pesadilla
para Rusia en 1999 Los rebeldes
chechenos radicalizados por clérigos
musulmanes extremistas invadieron la
región vecina la República de The gestán
pero no sólo eso los terroristas
chechenos organizaron los atentados más
sangrientos que os podáis imaginar en
suelo ruso dicho de otra forma que ya no
se trataba de un conflicto regional de
una amenaza para la vida de todos los
rusos incluidos los que vivían en Moscú
San Petersburgo Y qué pasó en Rusia en
1999 Exacto Ese fue el momento donde
entró en escena el hombre que todos
estáis esperando
[Música]
si no puedes con ellos Únete a ellos
el 31 de diciembre de 1999 Putin se hizo
con la presidencia de Rusia y tenía dos
grandes desafíos el primero mejorar la
crisis económica y el segundo
solucionará el problema cheno Así es
como comenzó la Segunda Guerra chechena
una guerra donde el kremlin impuso todos
sus recursos encima de la mesa y ya
sabéis lo que eso significa se estima
que murieron cerca de 15.000 civiles sin
embargo esto ya no era un conflicto
regional los terroristas chechenos se
aseguraron de que todo ruso sufriera las
consecuencias de esta guerra y creedme
no hay ruso que no recuerde eventos como
este chicheros armados toman 700 Rehenes
tras irrumpir en un teatro de Moscú
habéis oído bien más de 700 Rehenes de
los cuales 150 perdieron la vida pero si
este atentado no es suficiente para
helar la sangre en 2004 los terroristas
cheno rompieron todos los límites
Morales hablamos de la masacre de la
escuela de veslam en este caso un grupo
armado irrumpió en un colegio y tomó a
1181 Rehenes como os podéis imaginar la
mayoría eran niños en este caso 333
perdieron la vida así que una cosa que
pasó a ser indiscutible el conflicto
chino era ya una prioridad nacional y
como lo solucionó Putin ganando la
guerra pues no Putin solución a la
Segunda Guerra con dinero
[Música]
Putin se dio cuenta de que techania era
un lugar de señores de la guerra y
decidió apostar por uno que pusiera
control sobre el territorio por eso
apoyó con todos sus recursos a uno de
estos señores
hazmaderos de toda la vida hablamos de
uno de estos clanes chechenos
concretamente los cadirov han sido
independentistas musulmanes desde
siempre pelearon contra los rusos en la
Primera Guerra de Chela Pero hay amigo
poderoso caballeros don dinero en 2003
Putin nombró a este hombre presidente de
chechenia Un año más tarde fue asesinado
por otros separatistas chechenos que le
consideraban un traidor pero no hay
problema porque le sucedió su hijo
ramsam kadir off Y sí Este es el cadirov
que todos conocemos y que llegó a tener
millones de seguidores en instagram
antes de que le cerraran la cuenta
básicamente Putin regó de dinero y armas
a kadir off y le dijo Mira chico acaba
con todos tus oponentes gobierno de
zenia como te dé la gana y solo te pido
una cosa no quiero ni un solo atentado
terrorista más en el país y en esencia
Así es como terminó la Segunda Guerra
chechena y diréis y ya está la solución
al conflicto chileno era tan como cubrir
de oro a uno de los señores de la guerra
pues Por supuesto que no ahora es cuando
llega el plot twist más surrealista de
nuestra historia ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
Las Vegas versión musulmana
Así es como kadirófa ha reconstruido su
República tras la guerra y no solo eso
atentos al elenco de celebrities que han
llegado a visitar este lugar Feliz
cumpleaños al señor de la guerra Hilary
bajo fuego por el infame líder cheno con
todo esto pensaréis que este sitio debe
ser algo así como el Dubai del caucaso
verdad un sitio donde el dinero por lo
visto crece debajo de los árboles Pues
bien la realidad es que chechenia sigue
siendo una de las regiones más pobres de
Rusia de hecho es la antepenúltima
región Federal rusa en cuanto a pib per
cápita pero que producen por aquí pues
no os voy a engañar poca cosa
su economía está prácticamente en la
Edad Media en 2021 el 81% de sus
exportaciones era trigo ni siquiera los
yacimientos de petróleo que tienen son
suficientes para lanzar su economía
Entonces cómo se pagan esas mezquitas de
neón Pues con el dinero que llega de
Moscú y como os podéis imaginar todo eso
sirve para más que simples mezquitas de
neón También sirve para financiar la
propia vida de kadir off qué creéis que
pasa cuando cubres de dinero a un señor
de la Pues por un lado pasan cosas como
este el Debut en la moda Parisina de la
hija de kadir off es una bofetada en la
cara las botas de Prada de 1500 dólares
de líder checheno caleiro se vuelven
virales después del discurso de Ucrania
Pero esto es solo la parte más
anecdótica lo realmente preocupante de
cubrir de dinero un señor de la guerra
es que esos rublos van a pagar armas
muchas armas se estima que el ejército
de kadir tiene hasta 12.000 efectivos
algo relevante teniendo en cuenta que no
varía mucho de los efectivos rusos para
la región chechena el ejército de Rusia
se divide en cuatro distintos
principales occidental meridional
central Oriental y la flota del Norte el
distrito que cubre a chechania es el
distrito meridional que tiene alrededor
de 80.000 soldados pero si tenemos en
cuenta que cubre alrededor de 15
repúblicas distintas el ejército de
checheno no está en tanta desventaja con
el ejército ruso de la zona dicho de
otra forma que los llamados kadierostri
se pueden comparar con las tropas del
propio Putin esto es especialmente
preocupante si tenemos en cuenta que
chechenia se ha convertido en una
dictadura salvaje con campos de
concentración de homosexuales incluidos
vamos y al lado de kadir off hasta Putin
parece un tipo razonable por el momento
que diroff es 100% Leal a Vladimir Putin
a fin de cuentas viven una especie de
simbiosis Putin le paga sus caprichos Y
él le libra del terrorismo checheno La
pregunta es ha cambiado algo la Guerra
de Ucrania este equilibrio de poder Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
los hijos en acción
volvemos a las preguntas que nos
hacíamos al principio Quiénes son estos
temidos cadirobites chechenos pues
veréis son soldados leales a kadir off y
considerados especialmente salvajes han
sido acusados múltiples veces de
torturar y asesinar prisioneros vamos
que los Derechos Humanos no les importan
demasiado la reputación de los soldados
chechanos en general es muy antigua de
hecho algunos chechenos no legales a
kadir off se han llegado a unir al daes
es decir al estado islámico entre ellos
está a búho mar al que fue uno de los
comandantes más temidos del grupo
terrorista fue eliminado Por cierto en
2016 por los Estados Unidos los
combatientes de kadir off también son
expertos en el combate urbano
probablemente ya los habréis visto en
sus múltiples tiktoks durante la Guerra
de Ucrania
es un entusiasta de las redes sociales
de hecho tenía millones de seguidores en
instagram hasta que le cancelaron la
cuenta ahora se pueden encontrar vídeos
de soldados chechenos o del propio
cadirov por tiktok y algunos rozan el
absurdo atentos a este vídeo
[Música]
Yo tampoco entiendo el sentido de este
vídeo pero la mayor parte de los vídeos
que están posteando no creáis que son
tan graciosos más bien todo lo contrario
Todos hemos visto imágenes de soldados
ejecutados prisioneros arrodillados y
cosas mucho peores
[Aplausos]
[Música]
dijo que mandaría 10.000 soldados a
Ucrania y recientemente ha confirmado
que se han enviado 20.000 teniendo en
cuenta tanto a los soldados
profesionales como los reclutados Claro
que muchos analistas discrepan por lo
que sabemos se han desplazado tres
formaciones tácticas chechenas el
régimen cadereoff especial motorizado el
batallón especial motorizado Juke y el
batallón el batallón fue casi
desmantelado en 2008 tras luchas
internas de poder con el excomandante su
link llamada Jeff otro antiguo
separatista cheno por lo que si bien no
se puede conocer el número exacto de
tropas en el dichoso Batallón bostok
pero algunos analistas afirman que en
realidad cadirov no ha mandado más de
4.000 soldados vale que son conocidos
por su crueldad pero de verdad son
efectivos pues vamos a ver Cádiz dijo
que uno de sus objetivos era
directamente matar a zelensky y donde
han actuado mayoritariamente ha sido en
Mario Paul Kid y cerca de muchas donde
se encontraron cientos de civiles
muertos tras su retirada Pues bien la
verdad es que si fuesen tan buenos
probablemente hubiésemos visto otros
Resultados ya
le han ido nada bien las cosas a Rusia
combate han resultado ser iguales a un
soldado medio Lucky coffic experto en
política exterior y defensa y en cuanto
a la misión de cadirot de asesinar a
celenski tampoco le ha ido demasiado
bien
[Música]
el 26 de febrero las fuerzas ucranianas
interceptaron y destruyeron a un grupo
cheno encargado de asesinar a zelensky y
a solo 40 días de la invasión los
ucranianos destrozaron un convoy de 56
tanques chechenos el 4 de marzo las
tropas ucranianas también capturaron a
una unidad de teshenos y le requisaron
sus armas y hasta un vehículo armado Así
que con todo esto la reputación de kadir
off está en jaque en la primera oleada
no solo murieron un gran número de sus
soldados en los alrededores de justomel
sino que se tuvieron que retirar pero no
sólo eso uno de sus comandantes claves
ya también fue asesinado el general del
regimiento motorizado magomet tusayev
Muchos medios aseguran que puede que
kadir off haya dejado a sus mejores
tropas protegiendo a chechania y no las
haya enviado a Ucrania lo que está claro
es que por ahora están colaborando más
con la campaña mediática y de lealtad a
Putin que en el campo de batalla o dicho
de otra forma que estos cadirovices
pueden ser muy sádicos pero no son tan
efectivos como parece otro problema que
ha habido es que precisamente como los
chechenos van por libre han tenido una
pésima integración entre los comandantes
chechenos y la inteligencia rusa atentos
a esta noticia
y la inteligencia rusa las tropas
destacan que están bajo el mando de
kadir off y no de la jerarquía militar
rusa además A diferencia de los rusos
los chechenos han llevado teléfonos
móviles para grabar y subirlo todo a
redes sociales y como os podéis imaginar
esto es todo un regalito para la
inteligencia ucraniana
[Música]
no sólo eso además saltándose órdenes
directas de Putin hablan abiertamente de
una guerra contra Ucrania y no de una
operación militar y digo yo se atreverá
Putin a meterlos en la cárcel o ponerles
multas porque a fin de cuentas hablar de
guerra en este contexto es ilegal según
las propias leyes que aprobado Putin en
marzo pero la lealtad de los echenos no
se puede dar siempre por sentada los
caderobites consideran a Putin un boleto
de comida dicho de otra forma que cuando
se acabe el dinero probablemente también
se acabe la lealtad y hay que tener en
cuenta que gran parte de esas tropas
chenas son excombatientes separatistas
que cambiaron de bando por las
circunstancias muchos de ellos han
perdido familiares o tienen familiares
desaparecidos por culpa de Rusia ahora
se rumorea que cadirov ya ha retirado
algunos de sus soldados y Mientras tanto
en Moscú buscan ya chivos expiatorios
byden afirma que Putin ha despedido
opuesto en arresto domiciliario a sus
asesores de hecho el propio ha lanzado
duras críticas y declaraciones sobre la
situación atención si hoy mañana no se
realizan cambios en la implementación de
la operación especial me veré obligado a
acudir al liderazgo del país el
Ministerio de defensa para explicarles
la situación sobre el terreno y diréis
todos los chinos apoyan a Putin pues no
y cada vez menos lo hacen
a lo largo de la guerra en Ucrania ha
aumentado la presencia de combatientes
que se han Unido Ucrania pertenecen
principalmente a dos batallones El de
jojar dudayed y el Shake Man Sur estos
batallones están formados en gran medida
por veteranos de guerras echenas
compuestos tanto de chechenos como de
georgianos y voluntarios de azerbaiyán
la mayoría de los voluntarios echenos
son duros críticos del régimen promoscú
que dirige por ejemplo es el jefe
exiliado del gobierno separatista
checheno y anunció su disposición a
enviar a voluntarios que apoyan a
Ucrania el mismo cadirov ha tenido cada
vez más difícil reclutar voluntarios
para su causa en la propia seña donde
parece que cada vez la gente está más
cansada de ser utilizada por Putin como
hemos visto Rusia es un país armado con
costuras sino un bloque de acero
inseparable como Putin quiere hacernos
ver la Guerra de Ucrania puede ser el
detonante de toda esta bomba de
relojería que podría ser la
balcanización rusa Así que ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros creéis que
cadirov seguirá siendo leía la Putin por
mucho tiempo se cansarán los checho
puede abrir la Guerra de Ucrania un
proceso de Independencia y balcanización
rusa y qué pasará con la reputación de
Putin y la de cadirov si finalmente
pierde la guerra podéis dejar me gusta
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]